let's go next to our caller from the 917
area code who's calling today from 917.
hey david this is sam hey sam what's
going on
so uh i'm right now i'm 19 years old and
i try to engage with a lot of my friends
and talking about
political activism and stuff but i feel
like that the only thing that they could
talk about
is the instagram stories that they are
reposting
and i can't really have educated
discussions with my friends because all
they do is post
uh stuff on their instagram stories of
just headlines with no real
uh explanation or uh education for that
matter just
words um so i'm having trouble engaging
with my friends and i've actually
suggested your
your youtube channel and i'm just
wondering um like what is the best way
to engage with these instagram activists
and real change besides posting
something on their instagram stories
so you when you say that they're posting
instagram stories they're instagram
stories related to news and politics but
they're just basically
regurgitating headlines and not really
diving into the substance it sounds like
you're saying
exactly and are they people who are
aligned with you politically or not
aligned with you politically
yeah align with me politically and and
usually people who are posting stuff for
black lives matter for
biden administration but the way they do
it is
they're just posting uh straight
headlines with no real information or
articles supporting their ideas
so what i would ask in an empathetic way
and so the good thing is
you're not trying to change anyone's
mind here these are already people who
are on your side politically you're just
trying to get them to be better
activists and
so a couple different things one check
out my interviews about political
hobbyism i've done a couple of them
which talks about
exactly this issue which is following
the news
and like retweeting or posting stuff to
instagram it's political hobbyism
it's not really activism so first i
would check out those two interviews to
kind of understand the problem
then i would consider going to them and
saying
what is it you would like people to do
when they see you post these stories
like clearly you're posting it because
you think it's important
and you're posting it because you want
other people to see it what do you
envision
other people should be doing and
whatever it is they imagine
other people should be doing that's
probably what they should be doing
themselves right so if they were to say
well i post it so that other people will
get out there
and be in touch with their elected
officials or run for local office in
order to make change well
you could do that instead of just
posting to instagram right so i would i
would let them
tell you what it what action they think
would be most useful
and then challenge them to go and do it
themselves
all right thank you so much david all
right sam
thank you appreciate the phone call one
of our sponsors
today is hydrant and they are giving my
audience
25 off your first order
this has been a game changer for me this
is a refreshing
electrolyte powder that you mix directly
into your water
to rehydrate your body because it is
packed
with the four essential electrolytes
that your body needs the most
that's sodium potassium magnesium and
zinc
and because of how hydrant is formulated
it's an efficient way
of getting yourself rehydrated and it
tastes
awesome there's a variety of flavors i
have blood orange which i love
you can also get grapefruit and lime a
lot of us don't even realize when we're
dehydrated a lot of the time and it's
become a really a great part of my daily
routine
if i'm under hydrated i'm affected
physically
i'm affected mentally and i think you
never
fully understand this until you use
hydrant for the first time
i get a great a boost of energy when i'm
properly hydrated if i've been
dehydrated
they also have a version with caffeine
which i love
if and when that's what i'm looking for
everyone in my audience gets 25
off your first order when you go to
drinkhydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video